sarah if you could uh be someone else
for a day someone alive today you
haven't met who haven't met yet or maybe
you could do one who you've met who
would it be
kim kardashian
no joke the woman's brilliant i would
just like to experience like i just i
think she's got such an interesting
uh and very deep understanding of social
reality but you also said you have a
appreciation a love for fashion i do but
that but that's actually the same like i
just think it's really interesting
because we live in a social reality
which is completely artificially
constructed and some people are really
genius about moving through that and i
think she's particularly good i wonder
if she's good at understanding or if
she's i think it's very deeply intrinsic
to her so i don't know if she has like
surfing away how much cognitive
awareness she has of it or how strategic
it is but i think it's deeply
fascinating so i guess that's the first
one that comes fine
uh what about you lee if you could be
somebody
for a day don't say yoshi
don't say kim kardashian all right let's
do it off the table off the table no i
was going to say i would like to like to
be a
uh does it have to be here today i was
going to say i'd like to be um
the latest um
i would like to be the latest arm
processor i would like to understand
what i would like to know what it feels
like to basically um
you like being objects i like being i'm
always obsessed with being objects ever
since i was a kid what's the best part
of being an arm processor for a day i
mean i'd like to understand how i access
my memory what i anticipate coming next
and clock cycles what about how it feels
like yeah i wonder how it feels like it
could be
thanks for that
you